If you play the dragon, your deck
probably has a top heaviness problem. I
fought against my fair share of dragon
decks in the past year or so, and almost
all of them fall into this trap of
having the highest of highs, but also
the lowest of lows. What does the most
effective dragon deck look like in 2025?
I'm here to answer that for you. This is
Jyn with Next Level Commander, and today
we are taking on the challenge of
building the strongest and most
disciplined air dragon deck. You've
heard the phrase, too much of a good
thing is a bad thing, right? It really
applies to typical commanders. Most of
them are lucky to just scrape together
enough playables. But then there's the
dragon players. Man, you kids are
spoiled. This deck gets bombs in every
new set, plus entire product lines built
just for dragons every few years. And I
get it. It's hard to say no to that. And
that's why the typical Earth Dragon deck
ends up as a pile of mythic fatties
constantly swapping out old classics for
whatever flashy new dragon showed up
this year. It looks exciting, but it
leads to bloat and worse inconsistency.
You end up oscalating between massive
wind war blowouts and games where you
barely get to do anything. I mean,
there's nothing wrong with that. You're
playing dragon typo. That's peak Timmy.
And no one's going to stop you from
slamming the Bahamas and ancient brass
dragons. But if you're looking for a
more consistent and effective play
experience, something that still feels
epic without being all or nothing, stick
around. We'll be building the dragons
around the game plan rather than the
other way around. Our game plan is
simple. We want a board by turn five,
and this means dropping dragons by turn
three, turn four, the latest. But if you
look at the four drop dragons, there
just isn't enough of them with high
impact. So yeah, we want five drops and
that means we need early ramp. Our ramp
needs to be two mana and we prioritize
mana fixing. Normally I wouldn't play
cards like arcane signate index with
green, but the fixing is just too good
to pass up. And now we get to do the
first epic play that only dragon can
enable consistently, a five drop dragon
on turn three. And we're not just
playing any five drop. These ones, for
example, are much better when you have a
decent board. So, here we are looking at
the ones that are suitable for leading
the charge. We are applying pressure
immediately. And all of this is because
we want to be as aggressive as possible
because even though we do have some epic
lateg game plans like our commander,
we're still for the most part a typo
deck doing some honest damage. But a lot
of our opponents will outvalue us if we
allow them too much breathing room. And
one of the best ways to avoid that is to
drop their life totals down early so
that any hasty dragon we drop later on
becomes an unignorable threat. Drama the
Eternal is a great example of our
philosophy here. This card stopped being
cool maybe I don't know 6 months after
it release being replaced by a cooler
mythic gear version of itself. But
playing this over something like ancient
brass dragon may be unthinkable to some.
But pragmatism over flare. Imagine
dropping this on turn three. You'll be
smacking someone for seven on turn four,
and every dragon that comes after it
will likely get four than six counters.
That's a lot of pressure. Deploying a
board fast is sometimes enough to
straight up close up games, but usually
not. What we do for follow-up is the key
to the consistency we promised earlier.
Now, moving on to the mid game. This for
us should be sometime between turn five
to seven, assuming our board hasn't been
wiped yet. The next set of dragons will
aim to build upon what we have and set
up for the game onwards. They'll either
protect our board in some ways, help
refill our hand, or amplify our damage
to aim for some fast kills. The best
ones here are a target twinflame tyrant
colog and the storms fury is also
deceptively powerful. Kenobi gargantuan
is a bit slow, but if opponents can't
find an answer fast, they'll be staring
at some 1212 flyers crushing it. For
some reason, there aren't a ton of these
game finishing dragons. Well, if we
can't do it fast, we do it for longer.
Scale Lord Recker is the perfect
protection piece, forcing your opponents
to think twice before using any spot
removal. Wrathful Red Dragon shuts down
anything damage based like blasphemous
act. Also makes blocking really awkward
for your opponents. Call of the Spirit
Dragon is not a dragon if you are
observant. But shutting down most board
wipes while giving a small pump on the
next attack is the perfect way to top
off any decent board state. And if we
find neither of the utilities mentioned
above, the next best thing is card draw
to refill our hands and brace for the
late game. And for some reason, dragons
are better at drawing cards than dealing
damage. I will take it. Zerggo and
Ojutai is ridiculous value with any
decent board. Tiamat of course needs no
mention. One cast and you're set for
turns to come. Two-headed dragon doesn't
seem that powerful on paper, but getting
that five damage and two cards
immediately is excellent for just five
mana. Furrag does it in more convoluted
ways. It might be a lot less reliable
than other options, but it's one of the
most chaotically fun dragons in the
deck. No spine dragon is bomb. Now, do
not cheat this one in with attack
triggers or something. We have to make
sure the damage hits first. And when we
drop this to refill, usually you will be
drawing double digit. Also, our
commander happens to be a draw spell as
well. Just got to get it down fast.
Hawkeye Corser is the best choice for
that. I mean, this thing isn't supposed
to show up on turn five, but when it
does, soul boy is one of the most
overwhelming surprises your opponents
will ever face in the game of commander.
Like an end boss showing up way too
soon. Aside from Hawkeye Corser, we also
have plenty of dragons that help us ramp
into our end game. Turns out dragons are
not only amazing at drawing, they also
have over-the-top ramp effects. I mean,
just look at these two gold diggers. One
heist and we are set for life. And this
is also why haste is important. More
about the haste enablers later, but you
know who doesn't need enabling? Cluth,
unrival in ancient. This card does it
all on its own. Flying haste and even
without anything else, we get four mana.
But if you drop this with any decent
board, well, let's just say we'll be
getting one of those turns that remind
us why we play the dragon in the first
place. And now we're moving on to the
late game. By now, two things will have
happened. Either you've won, in which
case, congratulations. You can click off
the video now, or your board gets
cleared, in which case keep watching. We
are rebuilding and we're going
explosive. Getting one or two dragons a
turn just isn't enough anymore.
Patriarch spitting and airy ultimatum.
Yeah, just undo your board wipe. Oh, and
I get a few triggers. Majestic Genesis
reveal nine cards. Get all the dragons
immediately. We're back in the game.
Draco Genesis does it differently, but
with all the draw we had earlier, we
should be able to deploy this and swarm
the board immediately. Sneak Attack does
something similar, but more explosive
and more reckless. But if you just drew
15 cards with say null spine dragon,
this is one of the best cards to see.
Colossal Grave Reaver, Udvar, Hulkite,
and Ranny are a bit slower, but they are
all capable of snowballing out of
control if unchecked for just a little
bit. And of course, there's ancient gold
dragon, cuz remember the tokens it makes
are also dragons. A dragon tempest and
to this is probably the closest we can
get to a combo in this deck, as long as
you can roll better than me. And that
rounds out our game plan. It's fairly
simple. apply pressure early and keep up
the intensity for as long as we can.
Now, let's take a look at some
utilities. Starting with Monster Manual.
Getting this early game can really ramp
up our game plan, dropping one extra
dragon each turn at instant speed. In
late game, when we have the mana, you
can always adventure first for some
value. Black Market Connections gives us
everything we need, and there are tons
of dragon synergies in the deck, making
the changelings quite relevant. Be
careful with the life payment, though.
This deck is not great at gaining life,
and it's definitely one of our
weaknesses. Haste is really freaking
important here. So alongside dragon
tempest, we have teamer ascendancy,
rhythm of the wild, and why not
lightning grease. For removals, we are
going all board wipes and all one-sided.
I mean, we're in five color tribal deck.
There's a ton of those. Ruinous
ultimatum. Yes, we are going to need
some good fixing. Cruc of fate, we
choose none dragons. And for Kindred
Dominance, we choose dragons. Do not
mess this one up, Jimmy. And
deathbringer region is not the
strongest, but it's a boardweight on a
dragon, and we have plenty of synergies
with that. for more card draw. Great hen
just too good to not include in any big
dumb beats deck and stinging study for
nine feels like cheating. And last but
not least, we have one finisher in the
earth dragon deck. We don't actually
really need finishers. Most of them will
either do nothing or be win more. A
chrome as well is kind of like that too,
but it gives so much needed utility even
if it isn't used to win games. It's a
perfectly fine protection spell. And
more importantly, the lifelink can win
us some unwinable games. And if you
happen to have the Earth Dragon and a
few others out, this will get the job
done. For our land base, it's fairly
simple. We want the best mana fixing
possible because ideally we want to
start doing things on turn three, the
latest. We'll be starting with all the
fetches and five triumphs. We prioritize
fetching those when we don't need the
mana, but most of the time we will. So
untapped duels make a pretty big
difference in this deck. Shocks can work
too, but I don't think ETB tapped
options will cut it here, unfortunately.
And that's 25 lens. Add in some
fivecolor lands. I mean, the dragon ones
are so pushed. And yeah, we barely have
room for utility lands. I'm curious what
your choices are, but for me, I'm
prioritizing haste. Also, Mosford Bridge
as a land and a flash dragon for two
mana. That's just too much value to pass
up. Agadem awakening is a land early
game and mass reanimation spell late.
Just getting two or three dragons from
this is more than enough. And lastly,
two colorless slots. One of them I'm
giving to Alchemist Refuge. This card is
a bit expensive to use, but it allows us
to control the tempo of our threat
deployment. Sometimes two dragons on
your turn is not as good as one dragon
at the end of your opponent's turn. And
lastly, Vault of the Archangel. This one
you'll have to try, but life gain is
just too important in the average
commander deck. And we have close to
none. Top decking this late can really
claw back into a difficult game. And
just look at all the dragons that can do
direct damage. Sweet synergy. And that's
all the dragon deck for 2025. Am I
missing a dragon that is MVP for you?
Would you play the Vault of the
Archangel? This is Jyn from Next Level
Commander. If you enjoy this content,
please like and subscribe, and I'll see
you in the next video.